on the show tonight we have the stars of
the new bond film spectre but i'm a bit
tied up i need someone to come and save
me i wish that i wish they'd hurry up
and save me
hi
[Applause]
[Music]
and we discovered there's a formula for
finding out what your uh bond girl name
would be
and what you do is you take your
grandmother's maiden name do you know
this and your pet i'm the first pet
you've had no no that's a porn star
that's your porn star
that's a porn star name
this one this one is it's your
grandmother's maiden name for your
surname and then when you were a kid the
nickname you had for your genitals is
your first
one so i would have been winky reynolds
if i was a bond girl
um uh judy what would your bond girl
name be
just leave it with me for a minute okay
bond girl name
you know you want to tell us
i can see you on surface
hargreaves
[Applause]
yeah eve is better than that
what would your uh bond name be um it
would be binky morrissey
binky morris binky morrissey that's
adorable
you're a little binky
uh margaery
newman were you following the formula
marjorie
are you guys related
so you were the one who called it
margaery presumably no no no no no
she what not i'm not sure you decided to
call it marginal a previous boyfriend
i'm saying this in front of daniel craig
and my father will be watching somewhere
oh no
we'll just keep margie under wraps
what was yours uh fanula mccarrick
finula meet marjorie marjorie
very good
uh
vaults
correct yeah oh good not wrong at least
i aim that high
have you been on a british talk show
before
um
i might have but uh if i had then i
forgot okay you
you blanked it from your mind
[Music]
and naomi harris great to have you on
the show and what do you think about
yours actually you take such kind of
variety
of roles so people may not even know uh
that they enjoyed you in pirates of the
caribbean because uh this that's you
uh which is quite a strong look so very
strong
i try to actually rock that look very
unsuccessfully actually the like black
lipstick the dreadlocks it's not good in
real life no
where did you try to rock that room just
out on a friday night
who's she
she's been watching pirates of the
caribbean
and and the odd thing about when you're
making a movie like this uh daniel you
do hurt yourself a lot like in the in
the previous ones what's happened to you
um
i've had my right shoulder reconstructed
i have had
this left knee operated on my right knee
operated on
my thumb hurts
dry scalp
it's very difficult
so you get to do all the action running
around and naomi now last time you did
you you you trained you were out there
we've got a shot of you giving it your
all here you are look at that that's
great
she cares
naomi cares a lot more than that lady
does
does she even know she's in her she
looks like why are they filming me
shopping
didn't you have a thing when you were
you were doing action stunts with a was
that an extra when you were doing the
driving i was yeah i had to drive into a
crowd of people and everybody all the
extras were supposed to like park like a
sea for the car as you would do from a
moving vehicle coming in your direction
and one extra decided to just be a
kamikaze and just like dive in front of
the car
so i almost ran him over which was
absolutely terrifying was that a
money-making scheme on his part
not a team i don't know what was going
through his head but no i didn't hit him
because i have very good very very good
driving yes
yeah kristoff you weren't injured in
this film not on this one no no because
yes i'm trying to think you yes you're
happy
yeah yeah yeah you well you know you get
injured as you go along of course you do
mostly psychologically
but was it django unchained you to ride
a horse are you a natural horseman
oh
i think i'm more naturally a horse than
a horseman
but hello okay
if you say so
this slice of the story it focuses on
kind of the rise of queen a kind of
brief fall and then that triumphant
return at live aid yeah and is it true
that was the first stuff you filmed the
first day was that iconic possibly i
mean voted maybe one of the greatest
performances of all time yeah and they
we shot that on day one wow yeah
i think it was kind of a baptism by fire
but
it was it was a sink or swim moment
where i thought okay this is just a test
so if i can't do this i'm out of here
but the transformation is extraordinary
in here and a bit like keeping the
accent up all the time you did you keep
the teeth in all the time
yeah i had his teeth in because he has
an overbite a massive overbite which he
never wanted to mess with because he has
four octave range that he said i'm not
screwing with this at all yeah so i had
these teeth made i'm i was like you i
enjoyed it so much i'm not a method
actor i'm a method actor so let's stop
talking down method action okay
i have no problem with it i'm just
saying i'm
i've worked with i've worked with method
actors that i absolutely adore and uh we
can go on about that i'll tell you about
this yeah so you kept your teeth in i
kept my teeth in because
i never get a chance to end every
sentence with darling and deer
and freddie does and that's quite nice
it's nice it's nice being i'd rather be
freddie mercury for most of the day than
be rami
oh malek
know what i mean no
um
i know what you're saying by that and i
appreciate it
javier
pronounced correctly yes goddamn uh
listen silva is a fantastic villain
really really good and i think what i
liked about much he's kind of a
righteous villain
in that he he believes he is right on
his side
is that what makes him
more than a villain in a way
i think it's more reliable in the sense
that rather than being a person who
wants to destroy the world just because
he has a very personal
uh goal to achieve and he proceeds with
a lot of clarity on it yeah and i guess
that's more reliable it was for me as an
actor because i could understand better
what was behind that but even in the
audience like you sort of think well
he's got a point
you know it's it's yeah and there's a a
brilliant sort of erotically charged
scene between silva and james bond was
that the way it was written or did you
just kind of decide to do it like that
no it was written like that it was
really like that and he didn't encourage
it though
he found the flames
yeah we play with it and we we have fun
with it i mean
no they really do play with it and have
fun with it
[Music]
now er you you're quite the heartthrob
the ladies you know the lady is very
keen yeah
marjorie's gagging
[Laughter]
marjorie can't say enough about you she
really can't
but even margery might be put off
sometimes by uh sometimes you don't use
something with your hair some of the
hairstyle like in this you're you've
gone blonde in skyfall but you're
classic bad hair it won you an oscar in
no country for old men now i always
assume that
it is jesus
i always thought it was a wig but it
wasn't a wig no it wasn't a wig
unfortunately not
i had to live with that for two months
in santa fe
no matter what i did with it it will
always taste that shape so when i went
to buy something on the supermarket
everybody will freak out
and didn't you have to wear a hair net
all the time yeah i had to wear a
herniate and then yeah like yeah to put
the thing on place and then the last day
of shooting i i went to shoot and i have
to take an elevator to go to the first
floor of a building where we were
shooting and the elevator opens and
everybody on the crew were
wearing
the coin brothers were right there in
front of me with their with the thing
was the her name
yeah i know and then i realized like
that's scary it's scary because you were
so scary in that film
it's it's freaky that's what they paid
me for
i'm such a nice boy you are you seem
charming um because now daniel some
people you know they don't like looking
at old pictures themselves but there are
some quite good hair shots of you from
the past
oh don't get upset absolutely here's a
lovely picture of you and alex kingston
in mall flanders
it's all my own hair it actually it
looks like you're sharing the wig
it wasn't the budget for two
people just to make javier feel better
but this one is incredible the this is
um for our friends of the north look at
you in there
it is phenomenally that man is now james
bond it's
phenomenal because you were warned when
you went into um scaffolding you were
warned that this this is going to change
your life naomi yeah so how has it
affected your life it hasn't really
seriously like no drinks nothing no no
drinks for me but i i can go on the tube
the buses sit under a poster of myself
and no one knows at all
so
disappointing
get strangers involved
now naomi when you went for this did you
know you were going to be money penny or
did you think you'd be one of the bombs
no i was asked to audition as a bond
girl for the role of a bond girl and i
just went in for a laugh to be honest
because i know that they audition like
thousands of people all around the world
and i just thought i was one of many i
didn't really think i had a chance in
hell really of getting it
but was your money penny sort of a bond
girl no she is money penny but the idea
was that i would audition for a bond
did you ever find out what your bond
girl name would have been
um it would have been kiki martin
kiki martin okay
i don't know if you know how this works
last time uh daniel was here yeah uh
yours was a cock-heart grooves
basically it's your whatever you call
your private area
we've talked about that before
yes
we know what you call yours
and then the your grandmother's maiden
name what was yours again now kiki
martin kiki martin mm-hmm
as a kiki
as a child he says as a child right yeah
yeah yeah now i don't care
kiki martin kikimoran's a good name yeah
do you what would your bond girl name be
christopher
it would be um
well we called it horsey horsey
uh horsey horsey mayan
horsey
man wow
it sounds like a cross between
horseradish and mayonnaise doesn't it
i'll have that with horseshoe maine
hello
what's your name
denison paul denison
this is very sweet i don't know if you
guys seen this uh someone posted it
online and it's by an eight-year-old boy
an eight-year-old boy wrote this and
it's a kind of his review
of bond and through the eyes of a child
really this this does capture the
enduring appeal of james bond
so he wrote once there was a guy named
bond james bond
he was from england
he was a very good actor in movies he
has a friend named em james bond goose
in gun movies and he never dies in all
his movies there are different actors
some are not good some are good some are
amazing and at the end of the movies
there is kissy kissy parts
i like them
[Applause]
the other day this is amazing the amount
of money you guys raised there was that
uh auction uh for various charities of
all the bond paraphernalia and bond
momentos
the aston martin sold for 241 000 this
is the model there's a little
that went for 61 000 pounds i mean it's
amazing the thing a watch of yours 157
and uh judy you were in charge of one of
the star lots were you not i was i was
able they said would you bang the gavel
on daniel's pants
i mean
you know um
and they were estimated i think between
three and five thousand pounds and i
think they went for thirty five thousand
pounds
i got forty four thousand oh forty four
yeah was it yeah yeah all right slightly
soiled
was it your idea to reference the ursula
andres
thinking out of the sea or was it in the
script
it happened by accident really
i mean the blue those things came up in
there
where we were filming i was i was
supposed to be swimming across you know
and i was supposed to sort of stand up
and sort of look around
but the water was you know it's like
in some places where the water just
stays at this depth for about a mile
yeah so i kind of swam along like kind
of pretending to swim and then stood up
and was there and that's how the shot
happened so it was by accident more than
anything because i mean
you know i can see why they asked you to
take your shirt off and you're very
generous with your body in in this new
this new mode
in skyfall the laundry bill's very low
your shirt is a lot
do you you don't look like do you look
like that all the time or do you have to
get ready for these things no no i don't
i i i start training about
i know six months before we start
shooting and then and then and then
continually but
what's lucky about it is that we plan
out the sort of shirtless scenes quite
carefully so i can sort of decarb and do
all that sort of really boring stuff and
then the rest of the time i just eat and
drink
[Music]